Donald Trump will not stand trial next
month you know I hate to say I Told You
So in this case I really love to say I
told you so it was announced some weeks
ago that amid all of these indictments
with Trump trump was going to stand
trial in October of 2023 and I said
that's absolutely Preposterous this was
the Georgia prosecutor who was pushing
for this speedy trial I said what are
you talking about you got the former
president current leader of the
opposition you've got 18 codefendants on
this ridiculous unprecedented sort of
case you think that you're going to get
get your trials together within 2 months
not a chance in hell and that's the case
so this is good news for Trump in that
he's not going to deal have to deal with
this trial as he continues along his way
to secure the nomination which right now
looks pretty secure